[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is an
adjunct professor at William at
University and author of a renegade
history of the United States
Thaddius Russell welcome to the Rubin
report thanks for having me Thaddeus
Russell that is a name
sure is of a man who I feel knows what
he's saying you know to me like there's
some gravitas to your name you feel that
first of all my mother gets all the
credit
you know people sort of compliment me on
my name all the time and I say hey I had
nothing to do with it I wish I could
take credit for it but do you see that
as the pressure si there's like just
various I think it's unfortunate because
you know then I have to be good yeah I
have to sort of say things that make
sense and it's a lot of pressure for me
yeah you just put on me thanks I just
put an extra dose at there yeah now for
an hour you're gonna have to make
perfect sense no ma'am because you know
about this this is the internet pie
perfect sense coming up video people are
going to judge every word that comes out
of your mouth yeah I noticed that
yeah but I'm looking forward to this
because we're gonna talk about
post-modernism i think you have a
slightly different take than some of my
my previous guests you have an
interesting history so let's just dive
into it okay you grew up in a marxist
household in berkeley california I've
given a lot of good buzzwords right
there that first sentence what was that
like you could also have said the 60s
and 70s - yeah that's when I was growing
up yeah that's a lot I've been right
there that's a lot plus man named fatty
is run by dink here I'm kind of done I
mean we can just hop the interview now
ya know my parents were members of a
small Trotskyist sect it's called the
International Socialists and what they
did was they industrialized which meant
that they left their middle-class lives
and went into heavy industry and to
organize the proletariat for revolution
so my mother became a clerical worker to
organize the secretaries for revolution
my stepfather who had gone to Exeter
Academy and the University of Chicago he
left his world to become a steel worker
and a truck driver and his mission was
to condense the workers to rise up and
bring about a communist revolution so
that was unsuccessful
yeah I know what caused them to do it
was just generally what was happening
around then with the war yeah it's hard
you know it's hard to explain why people
come to particular ideologies but they
chose Berkeley and the 60s they moved
there and fell in with this hardcore
group and that's that was their lives
and so that was my life when I was
growing up and we had meetings in our
house and the comrades were sitting down
downstairs and talking about so I had no
idea what they're talking about it
learned later right but you know it was
heavy Marx's theory and which which
union shop should we infiltrate and
which Factory should we organize and and
then there were visitors to our house
you know there were Black Panthers we
lived about three blocks from the Black
Panthers national headquarters which was
actually in Berkeley not in Oakland and
they were around and sort of hippies
were around and members of the IRA came
and gave speeches and stuff like that so
and my mother one of the interesting
things is that my mother was the
dominant figure in my in my family she
was the heavy-duty intellectual actually
and so the idea of you know women being
weak or victimized or unable to compete
with men has always been just a weird
thing for me mainly an idea because she
was always the dominant force and I
always looked up to her and try to model
myself after her yeah so were you once
you became of age and started thinking
about these ideas did you immediately
jive with these ideas did you have
pushback or yeah I mean it's so I will
say that my parents as I recall did not
try to indoctrinate me directly but you
can't help it right I mean if you're if
you're raised in a church family you're
going to think that that's the truth and
correct and the way to be and that's
what I said I mean my mother said that
in fact she said this in one of her
speeches that when I was about 10 years
old she said I want to grow up to be in
the is that's what I want to be I'm
going to be a socialist how do I do that
and that was out of my mission and it
really mean that is when I went to
college I didn't know what socialism
even was yeah and so that was like I
said this I said I'm going to learn what
socialism is and then become a socialist
and it's sort of what I did for a while
and but that that we're off yeah so you
you write a lot and you talk about
the outsiders really the rebels I mean
the people of the drunk the fringes of
society the people that were probably a
dilaudid he's eating now you don't know
no not to people no God no that's a
misconception uh yeah my work so it's
okay we go please clean it up yeah so
know the people well okay let me let me
tell you how I got there first so I end
up going to Antioch College in Ohio
which is this ultra ultra left college
run by hippies and anarchists basically
and and punk rockers and in fact what
you think that's Evergreen State I was
going to say no I mean it's we used to
compete with evergreen from the most
politically correct the most left-wing
college in the country and we always
thought oh they don't know what they're
doing we are the true radical college
like that vests hilarious I think we
were the champions and there's I have a
lot of stories I can tell you about the
insanity at Antioch College yeah which
is kind of one of the reasons I started
to think twice about this politics and
the culture and well let's be keen to
give me one Oh just let's just dive into
a second because that's not okay a
missing job let me give you two yeah one
is just sort of tragic and disgusting
and the others more comical the tragic
and disgusting one was the there were
two kids at Antioch when in my third
year who had a an anti Christian art
exhibit and so they had crosses on the
wall and they had a fire in a barrel in
the middle of the room and at one point
they took one of the crosses down and
threw it in the barrel right everyone
there understood this was an
anti-christian statement oh no this was
racism this was the Ku Klux Klan those
kids got expelled Wow because it was
widely perceived to be an act of you
know via racist violence and they had to
leave of college and I was the editor of
the newspaper at the time and I said
this is kind of my turning point for me
I said what are you talking about this
is insane it really has this witch-hunt
feel on campus and it felt I felt guilty
and bad for having to come to their
defense simply to explain that had
nothing to do with Rader at all
yeah and then and that there was that
there was this hysteria that really
takes no prisoners
I mean you have to be you have to
eliminate the evil once you identify it
yeah why do you think that ideology
breeds that is there
because we're seeing this literally
right now yeah there's something that
goes on in college campuses actually my
mother said this to me when that
happened she said well you know what
they need to double they need to have a
devil yeah as soon as you step on campus
you start reading about the history of
oppression and you know I think a lot of
that's correct in many ways there's a
lot of bad things that have happened in
this country and elsewhere and then you
look around and you're an affluent very
privileged person in this world you're
in the top one percent or more every
college student basically is that
especially at Antioch so there is no
devil there is no there is no Bull
Connor you know there isn't there
there's no one like that around here so
you have to find one and so what we did
was we kind of focused on administrators
the president you know and his evil
administrators we just Disraeli they
inherently has to be even we assumed
they were evil and they were out to get
us and so we had to get them and so one
day two kids broke in one night two kids
broke into the president's office and
took a [ __ ] on his desk and that was our
that was our statement that was that was
telling him who was who it works at many
levels and what was what yes yeah so I
mean that those are just two the most
comical you know or worse things have
happened at Antioch in that way it was
also a very liberating place I mean
there was a lot of the hippies were good
in some ways I mean there was a lot of
nudity and smoking pot and lots of
sexual freedom which has gone now on
college campuses and I love that stuff
but I hated this puritanical left-wing
culture yeah and that's when I started
to move against it and then I went to
Columbia for graduate school and
everybody there is a Marxist or a
socialist or maybe a New Deal liberal
but everybody's on the Left everybody
and this was Upper West Side of
Manhattan as you know and yeah and I
wonder I needed to be a socialist and so
I started to study as hard as I could to
be a socialist and be a socialist
historian the I became a labor historian
which what you're supposed to do but I
started noticing that all of these
people didn't care what clothes they
wore they had no idea what movies were
playing they never watched television
they were completely oblivious to the
lives of real people and in particular
actually I'd say they were actually
hostile to the ways in which ordinary
Americans chose to spend their leisure
time
so popular culture was something that
was bad it was a false consciousness in
fact right this is a this is an idea
from the Frankfurt School from Adorno he
said this he said popular culture is
simply the way the capitalist class
maintains control and so we must do away
with it
I said that's awful it's worse than
awful it's totalitarian yeah there's
many arguments for saying that a lot of
pop culture is nonsense are dribble and
I mock it constantly but also people
need an escape it's also part of human
nature it's these are the things that
rise up that have some resonance with
people yeah I want to say it's better
than an escape so you know a lot of my
work is about Puritanism and it's long
history and that people aren't really
aware of how it carries through today so
the part of a pure of Puritanism is the
Puritan work ethic and a lot of people
get confused about this they think it's
all working hard to get a nice house or
a big television or a nice car it's not
it's the idea that work in itself no
matter what you get for it is virtuous
so you should work all the time no
matter what you get for it
so popular culture in this country since
it started in early 19th century has
always been honest and it's not just an
escape from that it's been in a way a
repudiation of that because the Puritans
and their descendants the Victorians in
the 19th century said all these things
are terrible at that time it was dime
novels which were the first novels you
know it was going to the Nickelodeon's
it was gambling was going to the horse
races sports all that stuff they said we
can't do that that's that's evil that's
Satan's work we must avoid that we must
work all the time and raise our families
and that's it so popular culture for me
has essentially been a repudiation of
the Puritan work ethic it's always been
this counter force against that in our
culture and there's this constant fight
between the two so you'll see like in
politics politicians you won't find a
president or a senator until Donald
Trump actually who hasn't criticized
popular culture in some way right
because they are they have to be the
models of the sort of puritanical
repressive good American okay a lot I
know all right no no that's great so is
there your to discussing it sounds like
there's a religious connotation there
people hear the word puritanical they
think of a religious connection but in
and of itself there isn't really a
religious connection right there they're
the ideas of a religious authority or
something like that but it's not
religious per se it's not necessarily
religious right so one of another
argument I make and I think this might
resonate with you is that modern-day
progressivism and left politics
generally is secular religion it's
really secular Christianity so in
particular I mean I think it's you see
you see they you see a lot of Pearson
ISM in left-wing politics and that's
been true for a long long time there's
actually a couple of very good books
about art showing that left-wing
intellectuals for the last hundred years
have been a uniformly hostile to popular
culture that until very recently these
sort of hipster communists in Brooklyn
who talked about pop goes until them who
all wear the same glasses he has the
same video where they pretend they do
and I've had arguments with them make a
hand there Lenin loved loved the movies
no I mean that Marx Lenin Trotsky all of
them you name it and on all the
intellectuals and universities who are
on the Left have all like Adorno have
all hated pop culture and seen it as
false consciousness because and I said
this once to a professor at Columbia
very prestigious feminist Gender Studies
professor once I said why why do you why
do you hate the fact that so many women
just like to go shopping or like to go
to the movies and she said because I
think they have better things to do with
their time I mean right so that's what
we're not just soundly judgmental so
it's elitist it's judgmental it's at
least authoritarian I think it might be
totalitarian and this is my critique of
the Frankfurt School not post-modernism
different thing yeah and I ride away
again I do want to get very different
things
to me it's totalitarian because their
idea is that your ideas are wrong false
that's their term they use that and
they're leading you to do things that
are counter to your own interests though
we know what your own interests are and
we know how you should best arrive at
them to gain them so we're going to tell
you what music to listen to what movies
to go see probably no movies but what
you do with your life right time right
it's it's actually totalitarian which is
why that crew the people who followed
the Frankfurt School in the 50s and 60s
the left-wing movements that they became
very attracted to during a time were
maoism with third world communism
because that's what now ISM looked like
it was this idea that we must rid
ourselves of our bad ideas before the
revolution can happen it's fundamentally
totalitarian it's about the total person
yeah all right so let's back up let's
back up yeah a couple things I think
sure to be bouncing around a lot here so
I love this concept of what you said
that Trump was the first one to reject
this because during the election I think
a lot of people noticed and I think what
people partly didn't like about Hillary
was that you know she's on stage with
Katy Perry then Madonna's doing a thing
the day before like just this absolute
connection between pop culture and
politics that started feeling gross it
started feeling like the powers that be
between entertainment and politics were
so in bed together they all hated Trump
and I think that then boosted his
support do you think that's a fair
estimate yeah and you think I was a
calculated move by him or was it just he
had been pinned into a corner because
nobody none of those people would back
and except a few of the deplorable
rejects like Ted Nugent and yeah I mean
I guess I don't have the same critique
of that that you do I have no problem
with you so but I just I take it a
different line on it I mean to me Katy
Perry and Madonna being front people for
Hillary is a contradiction because
Hillary represents second wave feminism
which was read betty Friedan if you
don't agree with me I mean you don't
believe me was a rejection of the
objectification of women in all forms
right so that any showing of skin any
sexual ization of women was bad I need
to be left behind free dance ed in her
book the feminine mystique that women
should become leaders of corporations
leaders of government and that's it and
she has several chapters in that book
that are rejections of sex in particular
and also she attacks gay men for being
eternal boys who are obsessed with sex
and for seducing housewives into being
obsessed with sex
this was free damsel thing she thought
that women were were themselves too
interested in sex and what they should
be interested in was work Puritanism
here you are right and so Hillary
Clinton is the apotheosis of that isn't
she right she wears the business suits
she is ultra rational she is ultra
disciplined she her husband gets exhales
where you go with that he does the bad
stuff right so she is this she is the
perfect second wave feminist so Katy
Perry showing her boobs on stage and you
know Madonna having done the same thing
before
that's a rejection that's a
contradiction with second by feminism so
someone's not understanding something
here I think Hillary just used them but
probably isn't really a big fan of what
they're doing right so you know there's
something there's a contradiction that
it needs to be resolved yeah do you
think though that that contradiction
like I think people see that even even
if they don't understand the full
history of it or the full philosophical
underpinnings I think people kind of see
that and I think that possibly did drive
more people to Trump do you think that
makes sense I don't know I mean it was
all Egyptian of all of it it was like a
just a rejection of just this this
monstrosity hi oh yeah I think that a
lot of people again I don't know yeah
and people I hate the way that people
sort of presume to know what Trump
voters thought yeah right better know
everything other way yeah hell we did
with my name is Thaddius I better now
yeah they you know but I do think it's
reasonable to assume how's that that a
lot of them were rejecting or reacting
to this repressive Puritanism in Clinton
and politics generally that is which not
just cultural not just about sex it's
that you're not allowed to say all kinds
of things if you're in American politics
right it's very restricted discourse
that's allowed in American politics I'm
sure that was a lot of what went on in
fact I did hear a lot of people say that
Trump says what he thinks yeah just that
was very attractive to a lot of people
and I that was attractive to me I didn't
like most of what he said but I did like
that he was breaking down the walls
right and Bernie to some extent was
doing that too you know and so I thought
that was very good even though I didn't
like either one of them in terms of
their content but I did like that they
were simply chow
changing the walls
[Music]